what do you see is the first foray so if
somebody goes from what we'll call not
well educated or not educated at all on
the financial side to okay I start to
understand this stuff what do they look
to do they want to buy stocks they want
to save like what do you see is some of
the first actions that they normally go
down and end up leading to being
successful financially really really
good question so and I feel like I have
a unique lens of this as an advisor so
one of the things that you constantly
and again we realize one of the biggest
issues here is debt consumer debt
student loan debt right so a lot of
questions that you get is how do I
manage just my financial life right like
and and debt leads the conversation I
have x amounted student loans I have X
amount in credit cards and one of the
things again whether a client comes in
and they have five million or they have
five dollars I say let's go all the way
back to square one answer two questions
for me one what is your first memory of
money is that your grandfather walking
you down to the bank or is it scarcity
like it was with me the Glen Lord
banging on the door right big difference
how you operate as an adult the other
thing is now what is your relationship
with money right what does that look
like now you get money what do you do is
it in one hand and out the other is it
immediately to save is it immediately to
look for an opportunity to flip like
those are habits so I asked those two
questions the next thing is I don't care
who you are where you from where you
went to school your color your favorite
whatever sports team give me three
months of your checking account on the
wall I need to know about you how much
you make where do you spend it how you
spend it how often you spend it I'll
know everything about you do that for
yourself and then I tell them I have
them come back to me and they're like oh
right I spend X amount of money eating
out or I spend right
cuz you had no idea you were just
operating as if so that's one of the
things just getting people to understand
the basics and people just don't learn
the basics of really what it means to
budget right really what it means a
personal finance to make sure that I
have these different buckets for
different things in my life I've
addressed the behavioral part of myself
when it comes to
those are two big buckets the last bin
is okay and here's that here's the other
thing is people say well okay well I
don't have any left over like all right
fun right
visualize take a white piece of paper
draw a line down the middle everything
that comes in everything that goes out
you've got a number over here let's look
at that number that's called
discretionary income if you have a
number on the other side we got some
issues so we could address that just to
make sure people get even but now what
then do I do if I have that number over
here I have $100 left over right and
that's when you get to people diem and
you gonna buy airline stocks right or
whatever so you start to get into
alright and I was just having this
conversation about savings right now
let's look at that I'll ease you would
want savings and savings makes sense and
that's the ultimate goal six to one year
of savings based on whether you're
single married whatever ku savings is a
privilege right from growing up in a
house where savings was never a
conversation because there was nothing
to be saved if you could save it's a
privilege
with that said there's conversations
where people say well I have savings but
I have credit card debt I have savings
but I have you know a $700 car payment
ab say well why do you have savings
right you should use some of that
savings to get yourself in a better
situation financially go all the way
back to what you're let's take your
credit cards what is your debt service
every month right
it's take it's costing you six seven
hundred dollars a month just to pay your
credit card bills
so imagine if you took some of your
savings are all pay that down now you're
paying 200 a monthly credit card bills
that leaves you a $500 buffer now you
could direct that money to something
else we still haven't gotten to
investments yet we're just literally
talking about managing your financial
life right and then you can start to
direct that towards maybe a immediate
savings bucket or directing that to
other payments that you have again so so
many different things that people have
um looking at making sure they're
maximize their work benefits which a lot
of people don't do right um so those are
really the conversations and people want
to get a hold of and understand they
just don't know how
manage the finances of their life right
well how do I a liqu ate my 401k right
what is this withholdings thing right do
i withhold one or ten or zero no one
knows that right there's no education on
that so it's really bare bones basic
personal finance but I take everybody
all the way back to the beginning of
memory of money your relationship with
money and let's just go bare-bones
budget keep your little app let's
actually look at it and then we can
start to address getting to that big
shiny object in the corner which is the
crypto and the stock market